my name is rodrigo obando
i'm with columbus state university i'm
in the thesis school of computer science
and the name of my talk is mining and
cataloging the computational universe of
cellular automata
a prospector's guide
the the this whole title was not really
in there the last part they
uh they said it was too long so uh
it's just a mining and catalog in the
computational universe of cellular
automata
all right so let's let's go ahead i have
a lot of things to go through but
uh hopefully it will give me enough time
to to
uh to go through the the uh the last
part
all right so um
you know one dimensional automata
cellular automata you know the rules are
defined by
uh k number of values and r's and the
you know as the range of neighboring
cells
that are used to use as an example you
know the eca
is k equal to 2 or equal to 1.
and for that we are able to find you
know a particular
rule that is represented in in rule
spaces you know where
r is equal you know it's greater than
one which implies there are many rules
that behave the same way so if you find
a a rule in a particular place you know
then uh you can find it in in in higher
ranges you know it would be exactly the
same
and of course it would be represented by
a different number so
uh i'm gonna i'm gonna go through a
process here
um where i show a
way to sort of uniform that and
uh you know that was uh that was the
abstract
and um
so in the introduction you know so we
traditionally would may define the rules
for one dimensional
oscillator automatic for the other ones
as well but we define them or declare
them atomically
that means that they are self-contained
and indivisible we don't divide them
now we define them for a number of
values k and for a range
r we use integers to identify them but
these interiors depend on a particular
value of k
and r so we also know that a given rule
for a value k
and r can be expressed at a larger value
of k
unfortunately the integers that identify
the rule are different
for instance rule 110 in the elementary
cellular automata
if your r equal to 1 is uh you know
it is the same as that long number which
is one billion twenty three million one
hundred and sixty three thousand six
hundred and forty four
and the rules pay defined by are equal
to two
in fact that same rule is number
twenty 28 270 in the rule space defined
by r
equal to three halves so even though
they are
represented they're really the same rule
of the integers used to identify them
are different
so you know you you uh
you see one and but you cannot really
see oh that's you know
the rule the rule ten or one ten you
know that's a big number
it's in another uh in another space
so anyway uh there have been many many
ways to parametrize the
the rules i'm not going to go into a lot
of detail uh into this because
uh this this is you know really really
uh
sort of old you know for instance one of
those gnomes it was lanterns lambda you
know a long long time ago
uh you know it uh this particular
parameter
it proved to be useful but it does not
give a good measure of the activity and
the evolution of the rules et cetera
and you know i i believe even langtong
himself said that you know it it
didn't turn out to be like he really
wanted it to be
uh so i i actually uh parliamentarized
this i
i published a paper partitioning of
cellular automata rule spaces
i did this in in complex systems back in
2015
and and i work uh you know a little bit
on that
uh and coming away to splitting the
different uh rules
uh into primitives and the way that this
uh
you know uh things i'm just gonna
briefly explain
you know these primitives you know uh
there are a portion of the rules that
affect the output depending on the state
of a cell
or the central cell that is you know
being evaluated
so this these are primitives and these
are the colors of the root for instance
this is the root plot for a similar
cellular automaton 30
and as you can see here you have the uh
you have the the the input you know the
two neighbors
and then the central cell and as you can
see the central cell for instance
that we call the i called primitive zero
is the subset where the central cell is
zero so
this one this one this one and this one
are actually primitive zero and the ones
that have
uh central cell one which are these four
that's primitive one if we were to do
this in more colors
of course there will be more primitives
so this is the the way that i
design or defined the primitive zero and
primitive one
so for instance uh rule 204 uh
in that one is the identity rule
has no no output changes ever that means
that in this case uh the primitive
zero you know is its own you know it
doesn't change
and for primitive one the ones doesn't
change you know
the same thing with 51 which is the
complement rule in this case this
actually
completely changes and every one that is
in zero
it flips to one you know in every one
that isn't one
it flips to zero that's the complement
and of course we have
254 other rules uh
uh besides those all right so uh i
divided this
uh if you're interested and see how
exactly how that works
uh i would recommend you uh reading the
paper
uh in in complex systems
so looking back you know uh back in 2004
uh you know i presented a preliminary
view of this
the the this thing uh
you know this rule space where i ordered
these are the primitives by the way
these are the
now the the different primitives and
these are the primitives for peace of
one
so the combination of these two and i do
have a function you know functions that
actually combine them so that they
create all the
rules in between order put the the
the rules in such a way that you could
uh you know identify for instance you
know this is a large
class 2 this over here is all class 3.
all this on this side is class 1 etc so
to me it was actually very interesting
the problem was
that uh you know it it's
it seemed like vitra it was not
arbitrary but it seemed arbitrary so
can we normalize this you know can we
actually do something with this in such
a way that it would be
um you know a little bit more useful
than not just for eca
so many people thought that the
particular orders didn't have a reason
to be
that we could order in a different way
and the distribution would change and it
was it was right
so we needed to find a consistent order
that would work for all
for all values of r and so we decided to
use the primitives and order the rules
starting at r equal to zero something
that actually not until recently had not
done
you know we always uh talk about the eca
as the
the first um uh the first rule space you
know that
actually shows interesting things such
as rule 30 and rule 110
and all the you know the uh the
different rules on
that aspect so we we actually
i i particularly never really looked
below that one because
yeah it's not going to be interesting
but then when i found myself
doing this particular you know dealing
with this particular problem i said
how about if we go back and look
at uh at the beginning see how they
unfold maybe i will find
a particular order in which you know
that will be consistent throughout
all the different rule spaces so i did
that
and you know very very uh simple rule
space
when r equal to zero
r equal to zero means that in the
consideration for the evolution
neither of the neighbors of the central
cell is considered for this
so we only have four rules the four the
the the zero rule which is the constant
zero
we have the one rule which is a constant
one so
regardless of what what the cell is it's
always going to be one
this one regardless of what the cell is
is always going to be
zero and down here and on we have a sub
h sub naught or a sub zero
this a sub 0 means that whatever is in
the cell is what are going to be the
output
so it's the identity a sub 0 here by
itself is just the identity
whatever input you have is going to be
reproduced for the next evolution
and then we have in this last one which
is a sub zero
complement you know we in fact whatever
zero we have it becomes one in whatever
one
becomes zero and then for the next step
it
also flips again and as you can see then
it's flipping constantly you know one
uh one and you know goes to one and goes
to zero goes to one
you know for all the input in here so
these are the four
rules not very interesting you know not
much of activity in fact
the blue uh tells me that
they are class one this one over here is
sort of
you know class two you know uh you know
in terms of the coloring
because this you know has some some
changes in there
so not very interesting but they said
what happens now when i go
from this particular space to
are equal to half and now we're going to
be using
uh you know this is for for uh we're
using cellular automata in order to use
the one on the left so here
we are going to consider consider of
course the central cell
and the neighbor to the left you know
which is denoted as
a minus one and now we see
that we have 16 rules and we have
zero again here which by the way is on
the same position as it was before
one here is also in the same position
that is the same corner
then we have a sub zero on the bottom
here also in the same corner
and then we have a sub zero complement
also in in the one on the right so we
have that actually preserves
the position with respect to the one
before
but now we have uh we have
uh 12 more rules
and this one of course they are uh
class two but this one over here is
class three
these two these are the complement this
over here you see this is the complement
of this one so these two are
our complement uh of each other
and now it becomes a little bit more
interesting of course
and this is for r equal to half
so if i continue the same thing and by
the way the way that this is happening
is that
there is a way that uh i can find which
are the primitives
that will go into this in into these two
and between zero
and a sub naught and the same thing with
this one over here
so that i can generate all the other 12.
um
again you know i it's just there's a lot
to say about that
all right so the next one is for rule
space equal to r equal to one
this is the eca this is where we find
all kinds of uh interesting behavior and
now what i want you to notice though
is that zero is still in the same
position
one is set the same position by the way
i changed the notation
to numbers because now it is a little
bit difficult to put
equations for each one of the evolutions
this one 51 over here is actually a sub
0
complement and this one here 204 is the
identity
but now you know where you what we will
find let's let's
take a look at you know go back to this
one you see this one here
you know there will be four new rules in
between these two and the four
new and here and four new in here so
this one if you see the evolution
is zero one two three four that's the
one
excuse me this one is the one that isn't
there one two three four
that's the other one is the same one one
two three
four so what i discovered for this is
that
the same rule regardless of where
i i actually mapped it it i did it
and you know for instance if i go back
to here
this is like a third from zero
to here if we consider this zero and is
considered one
this is at a third this is a two-thirds
if i go to the other
space now this one over here is a
one-third
and this one over here is also at
two-thirds so it maintains the position
you know the relevant relative position
with respect to the space
and it happens for all the other ones as
well
so here's uh 110 here is rule
30 just to give you some idea of what
things are
this is rule 60 this is 124 and we have
the complements which actually sit
uh right here 193 and 137.
uh you know this is us diagonally
uh speaking they are uh the complements
uh
et cetera so this is how you know it's
started to look
and and then i saw that you know i could
have a set of primitives and then create
the next set of primitives you know
given
that i had so i had these two primitives
with those two primitives i could create
the primitives that will actually
generate these two
and then i generate these other ones and
now this
is the ordering you know that i continue
so that means that now
i can generate the other primitives so
that i can regenerate the next step
which the next step is for r equal to
one half so i'm not going to show the
evolution of each one of those rules of
course
because the next space is equal to 65
536 rules so what i did instead
is uh i i did a
a list contour plot and then what i did
is i
i computed a computed the wolfram class
you know i just go through the evolution
and you know i
make an estimate of what class uh word
from class could that be
and then this is the 6536
uh are equal to three halves uh space
and now as you can see now look in this
in general
as you can see this all blues that you
see in here
these are class ones so them it seems
like the majority of class ones are
sitting on the edges and then we see
all these other ones which are class 2
and class 3 and there are some
areas there is some of course there's
symmetry but there's also
some um places where this
you know they the the class one will
show up again
you know at certain intervals so this is
uh what did and then i realized that
whenever you know when i did this for
the
with the eca with this one that the
rules still maintain
relative position with respect to this
square
so um because we have that
fixed uh position so we find that as we
increase the relative position
of a given rule or the value of r is the
same relative position of that rule for
a larger value of r
so once we find a position of a rule you
found
the position of that behavior on the
rule space regardless of the value of r
larger than the given value of course
using this method we need to compute the
entire set of primitives you know
so in the proper order so that then we
can position those in the axis and
generate the rules
so this becomes really time and memory
intensive
for larger large values of r for
instance for r
equal to five uh
perhaps you know we would need to
compete a primitive
in you know primitive set is two to the
32 primitives
and that you know becomes now uh
not a a nice thing to do
all right so um
so the generation of these primitives
you know we we were able to
to generate all this you know from one
set to the other
in in this it's an interesting way to to
do it it actually
it turns out to be a uh you know
recursive way that you can generate them
so so we wanted to you know
uh find this you know the transformation
that we had was a really a set
transformation we were transforming the
entire set
so i needed an entire set to generate
the next set
and that is what became a little bit
difficult without when you went
into uh the number of primitives like
this one 65
436 if you want to you generate the next
one which will be 4 billion
you know then you now you know if you
just want to know the position of one
rule
in this particular space i will have to
generate all this
which is a lot so uh we looked into this
and we discovered that the
uh you know that there is a
transformation
that can tell us for a given rule
and given uh the the the primitives
you know this is not done without a
partition of the primitives
but given the primitives we can find
what is the relative position
on this space that
that we created so this turns out to be
this transformation turned out to be a
permutation of the bits of the rule
which was
incredibly convenient so we also found
of course the inverse transformation or
the reverse permutation
and these two transformations allowed us
to then find the position of a rule in
the space
and then given a position and a space we
can find a rule that is positioned right
there
so
uh this allowed me then to do
not having to uh
to compute all the primitives now i
don't have to compute the entire set of
primitives so that i can generate this
uh
i can now say i want
this particular uh this particular rule
and i want to know where it is
you know so this manipulate over here
which is to me it's not finished
but um i'm still working on this uh i
did it i
actually centered it and right here this
is uh
radius one i i didn't do anything below
that because uh
it's really not that interesting but
here is 110
right so this is the right in the center
110.
and this uh two-dimensional
uh here that we can we can move around
i'm not gonna move it because i have it
just centered on 110.
and this is a random initialization for
the rule
the size is four which is four to the
right fourth to the left
uh and four up and four down
and then this is r1 so this over here is
rule 110. so according to what i have
now i can go
in between spaces you know i can then
take this rule this is my center rule
right now and then i go to uh
three halves and let me say am i
am i computing this
hopefully i am
um
[Music]
see let me go down this
[Music]
three
so i'm not sure this is computing oh
yeah it is computing good good good
i just was not patient enough i think
the fact that i'm
i'm broadcasting is actually slowing
down my computer for
to use with mathematica but this one
over here this is 28
270 which is the same rule right now
we zoomed in because of the of the
change in the three
uh you know because you know this is
what center 110 this is 110
but now represented in three and a half
three halves uh rule space
and now if i go to two so
i'm going now to the next uh
you know to radius or range
two so i'm considering two um
i'm considering two cells on one two on
the left and two on the right
and uh and this is it this is now
rule 10 but uh placed
on radius equal to two so
now i can do as i said is now with this
convenient transformation
i can just say okay now i want you to
give me
everything but at five uh half
which is uh two and a half
radius and let's let it compute
here a little bit and there you go now
this is
a lot closer and of course the the
number but this is the same rule
it is exactly the same rule and i can go
to three but this is you will see
there's a problem with this one
because i think it has to do you know
i'm using rationals for this
and there is something in some of the
math that i'm doing and this particular
manipulate that is
is causing this kind of behavior which
it actually gives me
all the rules to be the same yeah there
you go so they're all the same
so i need to work on this as i said this
is not necessarily finished
and i need to figure out uh why is this
doing this
but what this one allows me to do is to
go anywhere
so let's see if i go in here
and then i
[Music]
move around and this is the last thing
i'm going to do i don't want to take too
too long
before we get to the other things um
[Music]
okay so this is uh you know again 110
but and then i can move it this way
you know i can go and explore any other
place on on this
and as i said once we find one rule
we have a label for it uh it's a
you know k dimensional you know see all
this
you see and also look at the neighbors
all the neighbors they look
similar to each other etc so
you know this is a way of exploring the
space you know we can we can look at it
as you saw before
i saw i showed how
uh how the entire you know uh
one and a half radius uh looks like
anyway so for this we can label then the
the the rules in normal space there are
10 dimensional vector right now we're
dealing only for two-dimensional
and for instance just you know things
that we have heard about is
rule 30 110 137 137 is actually
the complement of 110. so here we have
this is the label for rule 30. so now i
have this
now i can with this number i can i can
go into
any other uh into any other space
and i i grab i know what what the rule
how is the representation of this
behavior
on that other space now this one over
here is 110
and this one over here is 137 and as you
can see
they are just swapping they if you swap
the coordinates
you know that's what you get the the
complement so
uh from from these two if i wanted the
complement of this one all i have to do
is swap this and then i will get the
complement
now this is the two normal space uh
function and this is the from normal
space function so from here
if i take the primitives like you see in
and here
then i can actually get back to 30 110
and 137.
so this turned out to be just uh you
know it's a wonderful thing that i was
able to do this i didn't have to compute
all the set of primitives but yourself i
stopped consuming
so now i could do all this all right so
in this case for instance i can randomly
select
a rule i just did it in the eca and then
i can basically represent it uh here
you know i can then represent the same
rule except for this one because this is
uh uh i think it's half
yeah half it will not represent the
world but all the other ones
they're all the same but they're all
represented in in
radius or rate range one one and a half
two two and a half and three they're all
the same
so this actually tells me exactly where
that particular behavior is
all right so um
[Music]
let me see there is uh this other one
these are some measure on the rule space
and i know i'm about to be
running out of time but then when i
looked at this and i said okay
so let's let's let's take a snapshot of
the entire
uh of the entire space so i measured the
entropy
this is the for radius uh three and a
half
and this is the measure of the entropy
throughout the space
and as you can see here the the dark
parts is lower entropy and the
the yellow
is higher entropy etc this over here the
world from classes
um i'm not identifying class four but
i'm identifying
uh one two and three and as you can see
the entropy
sort of lines up with uh with the work
no work on classes line up with the
entropy
and then one of the things that i was
interested in in in you know it was
langtom's lambda so i actually mapped
langton's lambda with respect to this
normal space and then i realized
that the lower the value in london's
lambda is actually
up here whereas in reality this
seems to be favoring to be low right
here in terms of the entropy
so when langtong back in 1986 he started
exploring the space he was moving this
way
and this is what most of the people have
done
through the last i don't know 30 years
they moved this way
and of course he discovered no it
doesn't really give us a good sense
of movement within the space but now we
see why
according to this the entropy actually
is lower
than this area and it is higher than
this way
but in this case this is lower so here
yeah it may look like it is like that
but in reality it's not
so anyway what i did also i took the
lambda
and then the lambda or the derivative
with respect to identity which is the
change in terms of the primitives i'm
not going to go into the detail
but that one actually gives you a better
sense
of navigation within having uh
low low class ones etc or low entropy in
here
with respect to this moving to the right
so this will be
the lambda of the derivative with
respect to identity will be a better
measure
to actually uh manipulate uh in
navigation through these spaces
all right so um
let me see
hopefully this will not um
die all right so in conclusion
you know uh because i i know i'm out of
time
so we found that this transformation
helps labeling the rule behaviors in a
consistent way across
you know values of art now that i have a
that particular
vector of rationals i know exactly what
that is where it is
you know we can explore now the normal
space at different levels of
magnification
as you saw i can go inside i can now
identify
this and then i can see neighboring
rules according to this
to these numbers you know i'm also you
know we're working on on transformations
for all the values of k
which will give us you know uh uh higher
dimensions
of course or or primitives will be
higher dimensions
and which is the number of colors that
you're using and then this will allow us
to represent
all one dimensional cellular automaton
in an infinite dimensionally
in dimensional cube you know like
similar to the hilbert cube
um so the initial findings also i don't
have this to show
but uh it occurred to me that i could
look now into this normal space and i
said let me take a look
at the functions remember that every
every single one of the
of the uh of the cellular automata rules
are functions
you know they are uh boolean functions
so
i said what happens if i take the
monotone boolean functions
um which are a particular set of
functions
um of boolean functions
and i put them into i put it into the
normal space
i think what i would discover is that
actually it looks like a fractal
as as we started magnifying inside
this particular uh space
i started to see the monotone bullet
function showing up and they will show
up in a very
uh similar way you know so similar as
you you were magnifying you're going
inside
you end up seeing actually the same
configuration from above
uh what is interesting for that is that
uh
for instance the number of monotone
functions given number of variable
variables has not been really
been solved completely on a closed form
we have found only
uh how many we have up to uh eight
variables
and that was found in 1990
um i think was koshinov and
and we have not done anything else after
that because the problem is
big o and factorial you know and we used
uh
a craig one uh using uh what is it 200
hours
uh at the time so if
this uh fractal that i see in the in
this space it's actually indeed a
fractal that we can
we can predict how it might actually
evolve i don't know we might be able to
uh find how is it that the number of
boolean number of
monotone boolean functions grow you know
as the number of variables
grow you know grows in here so anyway
this is as i said i wish i had a picture
uh i do have a a 3d view of that where
you can see
how when you find a marathon boolean
function you know at a
lower uh number of variables
and as you go down they are all in the
same position so it is
it is just fascinating to me so anyway
this is uh my talk all this is
is is provided in the files except that
i know that you'll be disappointed my
all my functions are not all cleaned up
so i did not put that you know but you
can you can look at it you can look at
all this the the pictures that i have so
let me
then conclude this in here and i will
take
um
[Music]
any any questions
let me see
uh this is um
emmanuel garcia says can you estimate
the percentage of class four rules for
each rule spaces are rows
no i have not done that in fact
the algorithm that i'm using um i
work with some other people back in the
nks summer school a long time ago now
that i
think about it and we just did that
for class three uh you know class one
class two and class three
uh detecting class four is a little bit
uh harder
uh what i can i could do i guess
is perhaps uh i i think i found that if
you
if you go to uh the class four like we
did with 110
and then you go into the bigger space
you will see
a lot of the neighbors that are also
they seem to be class four
but still it would be like you know
going around there and picking
uh some of those and if we
if we were to find a reliable algorithm
to the tech class four then we can run
it on this and then
we we can run it uh now that we have a
normalized space you can take you know
pick 110 and then you move
on on you know to the sides going up and
down into the left
and you know that those you know
neighbors uh are probably
also plus four and i also i also found i
didn't show it here
i found interesting things such as uh
a higher definition version of class 110
and when i say a higher definition is
that
the the when you look at 110
and then you look at this other one this
other one which is higher
definition it looks like it's better
defined
so if you were to sort of close your
eyes and
or maybe pixelize the higher definition
one you actually get
the 110. so seems to me that 110 is
really a behavior that is
is pervasive throughout and that you
actually can find
higher definitions of the same behavior
you know very interesting but i have not
really done too much into that
that that area
so i don't know any any other uh
questions
about this um you know if you have any
other
you know questions that maybe may uh
come to you
uh you you should be able to get my
email uh
you know send me a message uh as i said
i'm still working on this i'm trying to
clean up
a lot of my code
i i have uh
actually all this code that i used to
generate this isn't
more than one notebook you know then i
have to run
each one of them separate
all right
[Music]
i don't know if there are any other
[Music]
questions or interest
if if not and then i guess i will
stop here and i really appreciate uh all
of you coming to
to my talk thank you daniel it's nice to
see you around
all right